- [Gary Greff] It takes me about six years
to do a sculpture.
Six years to do one.
So, I try to work on it daily,
but, sometimes Mother Nature tells me
what I'm going to be doing.
I was born and raised
in Regent, North Dakota.
When I was growing up,
my dad ran the elevator
and was a farmer
and I just went to
school as normal kids do,
graduated from high school,
decided that I would go to college.
I then was in education for roughly
around 18 years,
was looking for the different job.
I came home and I saw that
the town of Regent was dying.
And that's when I started figuring
how can I help Regent stay alive?
and I came up with the Enchanted Highway.
I had no art experience,
no welding experience.
Okay, long and short of it.
The first sculpture I did
was the world's largest tin family.
You'll see that tin family
is all made out of tanks.
Oil well tanks make up the body.
Fuel tanks make up the legs and arms,
and somebody gave me some
green paint for the boy.
I thought while green and yellow
would be a perfect color
for the boy's shirt.
Not realizing green and yellow
is the Green Bay Packers.
Most of North Dakota is Vikings fans.
So I get grief on that one all the time
because I painted them the wrong color.
There's citizens in Regent
that don't believe in the project,
feel it hasn't helped or whatever.
But regardless, I know it's
helped and they always say
that you're not accepted
in your own community.
So, that to me will always be.
And now, pheasants on the prairie.
My sculptures are all made
out of reusable metal.
I don't use new metal.
I usually go to a junkyard, get beams,
get whatever I can get,
take it from there, flatten
it out with a tractor
and that's where I get most of my metal.
I don't have a shop.
Everything I build is so large
that I can't, I don't
have a shop big enough.
This is the knight here.
He'll be about 40 some feet tall.
He's standing here. There's his body,
there's his legs, there's his feet.
Then over here is the head of the knight.
The knight will be
holding a 30-foot sword.
You're seeing it covered with snow, so
I work out in the snow and rain
and whatever I've got to do.
It goes all the way to here, the sword,
it goes all the way to
here, goes all the way
and you've got a 30-foot sword.
Okay, the Enchanted Castle,
the reason I decided to start that
was because I figured
at the end of the Enchanted Highway
we need to have a hotel.
And I went to banks
and said, let me,
"Would you loan me
money to build a hotel?"
and they laughed at me.
And I don't blame them because they said
"We're not gonna build a
hotel in Regent, North Dakota,
town of a hundred people."
Long and short of it,
the school then came up for bids.
This used to be the old high school.
I started teaching. I started
here, I was not teaching,
I was playground supervisor,
annual staff advisor, bus
driver when I started here.
But I did graduate from here.
This was the superintendent's
office, principal's office.
This is the high school gymnasium.
It's got two eight-man hot
tubs in the locker room.
Why the Medieval theme?
Everybody in town sort of
wanted to stay as a school theme.
I felt that didn't tie in
with the Enchanted Highway.
What ties in with the Enchanted
Highway besides a castle?
Okay, in North Dakota,
I felt there couldn't be
a Disneyland castle, but a Medieval castle
would fit the area of the
North Dakota that we have.
This is right where I sat
when I graduated from high school.
When I graduated, I was 18 years old
thinking, "Wow, I can't wait to get out
to a party, to get out of
school, get out of this school."
And never once thinking that
I would ever, ever, ever
have turned it into a tavern.
My closing words is that,
is to come in to Regent
and Enchanted Highway
and basically see what one man
that never laid a bead
of weld in his life,
never had an art class.
With one man can do this,
it's proof that you,
that you can do whatever
you set your mind to do.